every age has a cut off so every guy is  like  every guy has a so your mom has no value  my Mom has nobody yeah I've talked to my  mom about this in the sexual Marketplace  nah good luck my mom on the dating scene  you're telling me my mom like I love I  love you Mom I love you he's talking  about no it's not not personal words  it's sexual market value so I mean most  guys will date a girl for 25 though she  looks good true true so maybe maybe he's  pickier he prefer girls under 25 the  point is women under over the age of 25  typically we've had our heart broke  Hearts broken and men have to deal with  that so it's easier to get with a  younger girl who hasn't hasn't had drama